[Music]
all right parker
you ready
world if you're watching
wish me luck
exclusively in cinemas coming
soon all right parker you ready
[Music]
do it
exclusively in cinemas
we tamper
with the fabric of reality
what's happening starting to come
through and i can't stop him
i can't believe i'm in the saints i'm
saying it's horum
neither can i
we started getting some visitors from
every universe hello peter it's been
very nice to come back to something that
is familiar but at the same time
completely
parker i am new
confused right now 20 years since his
green goblin
17 years since my first time as doc what
was your name again dr otto octavius
seriously what's your actual name we got
another chance to stir some things up
oh you like the noodle electro is like
the world did me wrong now i got this
energy i'm about to go get mine you're
not gonna take this away from me
darkhawk picks up where he left off what
have you done with my machine he's
looking for revenge do you want to play
games
the goblin believes in a world of losers
and winners power is all that matters
[Music]
it's a wonderful world to be in we're
having a lot of fun they're a danger to
our universe we need to send them back
looks like we got competition
i think people are going to be really
surprised they're going to marvel
[Music]
you